j'ai appris comme vous par la presse que
il y avait des associations et des élus
qui avaient décidé de saisir la justice
c'est normal que la justice fasse son
travail elle le fait librement elle va
faire justement la lumière sur sur ce
sujet mais comme votre confrère l'a très
bien rappelé je crois que le cœur de
l'enquête n'est pas votre serviteur je
m'abstiendrai de tout commentaire ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que les comptes
de campagne ont été déposés en 2017 et
ont été validés que les contes de
campagne ont été déposés en 2022 ils
sont en cours de validation il y a une
instruction qui est en cours il faut
laisser la justice faire son travail
est-ce que vous attendez à être
perquisitionné ce qui compte c'est ce
que nous faisons pour répondre aux abus
qui ont eu lieu sur le recours à des
cabinets de conseils extérieurs moi je
le reconnais bien volontiers je pense
que nous sommes allés trop loin qui a eu
à certains moments des des missions qui
étaient donnés dont on peut se demander
si elles étaient totalement je les excès
des abus evidemment une explosion le
Sénat il y a par ailleurs la crise de
covid pour laquelle il y a eu
effectivement un certain nombre de
missions qui ont été donnés sur la mise
en oeuvre de la politique de vaccination
en 2001 Paris n'était pas endetté et sa
dette atteint aujourd'hui 7,7 milliards
d'euros est-ce qu'il faut mettre Paris
sous tutelle ah une situation financière
qui est grave effectivement et qui n'est
pas contrairement à ce que dit Lego lié
à la covid en Chine le peuple commence à
se révolter contre la politique du Zéro
covid plusieurs manifestations ont eu
lieu plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
rassemblés à Pékin à Shanghai dans la
foule et c'est assez rare pour être
signalé le président a même été
directement ciblé chez inping démission
ont osé crier certains contestataires la
dette depuis le début du mandat de
Madame Delgo depuis 2014 a doublé il y
avait pas le covid en 2014 donc il faut
assumer ses responsabilités mais donc
est-ce que c'est un scénario que la
Ville de Paris puisse être mise c'est un
scénario possible c'est pas exclu mais
le fait même on en parle vous imaginez
bien pour la capitale c'est gravissime
300 étudiants mobilisés devant une
université très réputée il chante
l'hymne national
il risque 50 prisons en venant
aujourd'hui manifester le chef de l'État
avait dit qu'il ne fallait pas politiser
le sport pourtant hier soir dans une
série de tweets il ne sait pas privé de
le faire entre deux encouragements
adressés au bleu Emmanuel Macron a fait
une déclaration politique évoquant je
cite des changements qui sont à l'oeuvre
au Qatar un chemin entamé par ce pays
qui peut compter sur le soutien de la
France après le président de la
République a raison de rappeler que le
Qatar est un partenaire de la France un
partenaire commercial partenaire
culturelle et donc d'état à état de
responsable politique à responsable
politique nous voulons faire évoluer le
Qatar je crois que c'est le sens du
tweet du président de la République des
mots qui ont suscité de vivre et
réactions notamment
de la France insoumise la députée Daniel
obono dénonce je cite un message
publicitaire sponsorisée par les miracs
du Qatar c'est un soutien précisément
pour que les choses évoluent c'est ça
c'est pas un soutien sur l'état actuel
ou ce qui aurait été fait merci un
soutien dans le cas où il y aurait une
évolution sur un certain nombre de
sujets qui sont des sujets graves alors
doit-il démissionner
non nous n'avons pas à ce jour pris
cette axe pour Adrien catenin sorphange
nous avons pris des positions qui sont
des positions fortes est-ce que je
considère que après avoir reconnu des
faits comme cela on peut sereinement
exercer son mandat dans l'hémicycle et
représenter les électeurs je pense que
c'est compliqué je milite depuis 25 ans
contre les violences faites aux femmes
c'est un de mes combats majeurs et que
pour moi il est hors de question que les
principes féministes qui guident notre
mouvement soit quelque part mis de côté
parce qu'il s'agit d'un de nos camarades
l'Italie sur l'île 10 Kia au large de
Naples les recherches se poursuivent
après le glissement de terrain qui a
fait une dizaine de disparus hier
heureusement le beau temps est revenu ce
qui va faciliter le travail des secours